direction le Sud Touraine à
Preuilly-sur-Claise ou les poids lourds
ne sont plus les bienvenus le maire
vient de prendre un arrêté interdisant
la circulation des camions de plus de 17
tonnes dangereux pour les piétons c'est
miroirs dégradent également les
trottoirs la chaussée et parfois même
les habitations une situation devenue
insupportable pour les riverains et les
élus les explications de Romain Delville
Preuilly sur claises n'en peut plus du
trafic de poids lourds dans la commune
raccourci entre l'avant et la 10 sur
l'axe Châtellerault Châteauroux Preuilly
subit les dégradations dues à la
circulation des gros tonnages une
trentaine recensée en 2022
les enseignes de magasins il y avait une
demi-douzaine sur la NES seulement donc
ça commence à bien faire des potelés
déjà et les barrières de protection de
piétons voilà puisqu'on emprunte le
trottoir pour se croiser donc il faut
arrêter ça le conseil municipal qui ne
peut agir vis-à-vis de la route
départementale 725 a voté un arrêté
municipal qui interdit la circulation
des camions de plus de 17 tonnes 5 dans
la commune les déviations il y a
toujours les pours et les contre dans ce
genre de solutions mais c'est vrai que
la solution de dévier tous les poids
lourds donc après aussi il faudra de
maintenir tous les tous les véhicules
légers comme dans le centre bourg parce
que comme je dis souvent on a rarement
vu un poids lourd un 38 tonnes et un 42
tonnes s'arrêter pour acheter le journal
ou une baguette de pain des camions dans
des villages trop étroits pour les
accueillir c'est le lot de nombreuses
communes et proies a décidé d'agir le
maire il est responsable de la sécurité
des administrés de la sécurité de la
voirie et aujourd'hui il est confronté à
un problème qu'il n'a pas créé il est la
victime d'une situation qui est la
situation géographique en quelque sorte
de son village avec des barrières de
protection et des blocs de béton sur les
trottoirs deux poids lourds ne pourront
plus se croiser rue Chaumont patin sur
l'axe de la D725 les travaux sont prévus
au premier semestre 2023